[Music]
happy Rosh Hashanah that's right today
is Rosh Hashanah the Jewish New Year and
by the way Rosh Hashanah is Hebrew for I
have no writers today
I'm not kidding none of them showed up
even the Irish Catholic ones oh I gotta
go to shul son had the improvising today
who needs writers when I can do that
with my body I should use the writers
excellent show hey big big day in LA
Mitt Romney's in Los Angeles today for a
fundraiser then Romney's here yeah so
that's one more handsome guy in LA
auditioning for a role he probably won't
get
it's got amazing hair
the handsome fellow Mitt Romney trailing
in the polls there so they're trying to
weather his campaign trying to change it
up after being accused of being too
vague Mitt Romney's campaign team says
they will start being more specific now
when asked when they said
soonish this is crazy I couldn't leave
this Arnold Schwarzenegger is in the
news Arnold Schwarzenegger has written a
new book about his affair with his
Hispanic housekeeper and the book is
actually called Total Recall that's true
that's not a joke that's not a joke he's
calling it Total Recall
in response she's written a book about
the roof air called alien versus
Predator
lullaby
you gotta bite my Bugatti thousand
flowers of God is what were they asking
what are you gonna call it Total Recall
hey you know I only have five ideas you
know he went through all of his movie is
Junior know
all the Judeo in Rome a tabloid is
running some of the new topless photos
of Kate Middleton where her breasts
appear larger than in the earlier photos
a couple days ago and that weird yeah
when he heard about it Prince Harry said
why can't my photos be in that magazine
because they make things larger I looked
and I saw my soul when I looked and it
wasn't pretty
a new study reveals that single people
pay more money than married people on
food shelter taxes and health insurance
and yet they make less money than
married people yeah after hearing this
every single guy said still worth it
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies gentlemen man in Kentucky is
suing a doctor for amputating his penis
unnecessarily yeah when the doctor
apologized the patient said no hard
feelings
[Applause]
[Music]
I apologize that's what happens on Rosh
Hashanah we went through Old Dixie
riddle cups the really dirty Dixie real
gut